michael taft welcome to simulation
thanks atlas happy to be here
super excited for this episode talking
about deconstructing yourself
something that
i can say through
my experiences
at the
cornerstone of
realization
and
i feel like it would be good to perhaps
start with you
on
what i've been sort of calling like an
identity vortex
of sorts
um
do you
see
um
identity and uh name
and
um
all of our uh likes and dislikes our
cravings and our aversions
um
do you see that all playing into
um the mind and playing into the mind
making a lot of noise and
then um
when it's difficult to then quiet the
mind um that's what then makes it
difficult to realize what one's true
nature is so do you sort of see like an
identity vortex like that that has a lot
of noise it has a lot of name it has a
lot of um
sort of following the buddha's dependent
origination
yes i mean that's it
if you it's funny you're using the
vortex image if you go there's a video
of me talking at the science and
non-duality conference from about 2012
where
i have a i have a slide of a vortex and
show how for example verbal type
thinking and visual thinking and
various emotions and and cravings and
body sensations and so on all kind of
swirl together into this vortex that
kind of pulls
attention in
um
and you know this is of course
idea that
that has a kind of magnetic pull
that that keeps drawing us and drawing
us in
and um
drawing us away from
our uh let's say true nature
uh of course is pretty standard
understanding right and i think it's
very accurate
yet because it is really uh confluence
or uh amalgamation of sorts of uh yeah
of identity and of uh sensation
and of um
just a lack of awareness
and a
um just a
a
overlooking of consciousness and
overlooking of
of um
uh like the power to know overlooking uh
something that's so
uh
yeah like indescribably
here and that is uh
yeah it's just so overlooked and it's
yeah it's a vortex of all that stuff
identity sensation um
and so then do you when you walk people
through um
sort of deconstructing themselves
um where do you usually
see the majority of people like
liberating themselves with seeing that
freeze
yeah so it's no
surprise
that uh people overlook
um
the awareness component because
the awareness component in a way
to use a really clunky metaphor is like
the light in a room
right you've got this big empty room
there's and there's bright lights in it
and um
what everyone is paying attention to
is all the stuff that comes and goes in
the room
the different furniture and the
different people and the different
animals
um you know pets and so on
uh that come and go from the room and
the clothes they're wearing and all that
and because that's the changing part
that really captures
our attention
um
and
because it's been
so long since we noticed any time when
that
or to put it another way the room is
never blank unless we're asleep and in
deep sleep and most of us don't notice
that
and so
[Music]
it's become such a given it's just
become such a normal background
it's like the fish and the water problem
so
it's very hard
to remember to notice
it's just like paige's book
whether you're doing a kindle book or a
physical book
um when was the last time you actually
looked at the page itself
the like the paper the white paper
between the letters
uh probably a long time because you've
just come to
assume that page is there and forget
that it's
actually the
fundamental and completely necessary
substrate
for the letters to exist
and so even though it's incredibly
important you couldn't have a book
without it
um in one way it's the most important
part
it's very easy to overlook it's very
easy to forget
um and instead pay attention to just the
letters and the words
or uh to leave the metaphor pay
attention to just our thoughts just our
emotions
just the stuff that's coming and going
in our sight and vision our sight and
hearing in our body and so on
really get focused on that
and forget
what's
focusing what is that that fundamental
experience itself
right the fundamental fact of experience
experience with no
uh
clutter at all
or
uh if we get if we even experience with
clutter but noticing the awareness right
that's very very important and yet super
easy i never
super easy to not notice i never
uh think less of someone for the fact
that they don't notice that
um
what are most people involved in instead
of that well everything right they're
involved in
you know pokemon go they're involved in
uh
their
career they're involved in
what they're worried about they're
involved in politics they're involved in
um
knitting and crochet or something who
knows there's so much to be involved in
and we've
as a society we've mastered the art of
entertainment and involvement and
keeping attention
stimulated with fun stuff like new
colorful bright things in the room all
the time
and so
and there's nothing wrong with that
that's fabulous
except
it's
not helping us notice this fundamental
thing
and without noticing the fundamental
thing
awareness itself
we kind of miss
uh the most important thing about our
lives
and so in other words you can kind of
distract yourself to death you can
and never notice what's really going on
and
it's worth noticing what's really going
on and honestly
to do it at least to a reasonable degree
is just not that hard
yeah you know
it's just not that hard
um teachers have known for thousands of
years that you can take
just some person off the street an
average person off the street
and with a little pointing out
instruction at least get them to notice
regular old awareness
uh itself at least for a moment
yeah at least for a moment and that's
pretty shocking like it just with
someone who knows what they're doing
they can
point to this important feature of your
own experience
for most people not for everyone but for
an average person off the street they
can show you how to notice that in two
minutes or three minutes
at least for a second
and i think that's kind of amazing
um it's not that hard what's hard is of
course then sustaining that noticing of
awareness and of course
going from
regular old um
uh awareness where everything's reified
to awake awareness where nothing's
reified right so there's a lot going on
in there but in another way it's just
not that hard to begin
it's just nothing in our society nothing
at all
uh in the regular part of society anyway
supports you noticing that
everything supports you
not distressing you yeah
yeah that's so cool
so then
would you say that these
like very uh childlike analogies um
like
um
like helping someone realize that
they've been uh sort of paying a lot of
attention to the words on the page and
then to sort of recognize the paper that
the words are written on um and then to
collapse the duality between those two
um
and would you say that that
and like maybe the
the fish in the ocean analogy
um
and these um would you say that that's
uh one of the easiest sort of ways uh
when you serve others that are uh
seeking and trying to
understand what their true nature is you
kind of give them these very fundamental
kind of child-like analogies and you
found that to be useful i definitely
have
yeah the analogies are useful
it's helping to point to what we're
trying to point at right
so um the analogies are useful
being pointed to the thing is useful
um i find that most people including me
especially me
um
need to hear this stuff over and over
and over and over and over
because it's not
about the content of
like the intellectual content
it doesn't really help very much that's
all analogies are so great
yes
it's about hearing it over and over and
over enough times to start actually
noticing it
in your experience and then
more importantly
stabilizing that notice
yes
cool so then you would say that um
generally the shift that um you're
serving people with is to notice
um that the thoughts and the appearances
are like the words on the page and then
to sort of recognize the paper and then
to stabilize um in the paper and then
collapse the duality that that's
typically the way that you're
addressing this
that's typically the way but there's a
million ways that's kind of an overview
there's a million
tactical
detailed ways
to fulfill that for folks and
i would also say it's really important
to remember that in the long run
all the material all the thoughts and
emotions and
external world and you know all the
things that are going on in awareness
are um
just as important just as non-dual just
as
fabulously interesting
but simply
we need to get them out of the way long
enough or calm them down long enough so
that we can see
the awareness right we want to
show you some pretty blank pages so you
can
remember what it's like to look at a
page
but once that gets you know kind of
stable then allowing thought and
allowing feeling and allowing the world
to come back in that's the real
non-duality
right
that's what it means
that the words on the page actually
aren't separate
we just
most people have to go through this
process of kind of you know
um
getting into
pretty blank pages to just to notice it
and stabilize it
yeah
and in terms of all the different like
tactful um
approaches
to this like have you noticed uh a
powerful pattern
um where there's a a specific way that
works most
most of the time for people
no and this is for a very important
reason and the important reason is that
everybody is really different
and if there was one right way
you know these all the techniques that
we use for this have been around for
thousands of years you know
if there was one way that was so much
better than the others it would have
taken over a millennium ago
and all the other ones would just be
forgotten because
no one wants to spend extra time or
effort
learning this right everyone wants
to do this as quickly as possible but it
turns out that and you know i've been
teaching for a long time and i've taught
a lot of people and it's like
what and one-on-one not in big groups
and what do you notice when you work
with people one-on-one
man
their minds are really different and so
um
that said
even though there's not one right way
you know there are a few
standard
uh let's say let's say a palette of five
or six kind of general directions
that really help
but i don't think there's one big
panacea you know or one big solution
whew just change sides
at least i could see you now
yeah yeah and i think uh the internet
connection is a bit more stable also
um
yeah you were talking about how um
the
um
there's not just a single uh pointing
that's most efficient or there's not a
single there's not really a single
pattern per se that is
most uh successful at getting people to
deconstruct themselves but you do find
there's like some sort of a power law
though of like the most common things
that people sort of let go of or
dissolve on their path
yeah it's not about the power law part
it's about that there's you know instead
of being one right way there's several
ways
you know and
uh
we know these right again like i say
most of these techniques are thousands
of years old so
um
for some people we do
an elaborate
deconstruction
of these sensory streams
you know like okay notice that your
thoughts are dissolving all the time and
not stable and if we want to you know
get buddhists we can say they're
impermanent and empty
um now notice that your emotions are the
same way now notice that your body's
sensations are the same way and we just
walk them through
that
uh
deconstruction of these sensory streams
so you know there's a lot of traditions
that use that because
that works for a lot of people
but it's not the only way right another
way is inquiry
right we can start asking questions that
when you really try to find the answers
to those questions not in your mind not
conceptually but looking directly
looking directly looking directly
it starts to
either somehow deconstruct
or some of the other ones just point to
the awareness directly
in a questioning way
so inquiry works really well
of course
sometimes
the initial
pointing tool
can happen from drug experiences or
altered states brought about even by
injury and stuff
but you can that clears the decks enough
um there's also just the shamatha route
which
you know um
won't necessarily take you all the way
but the kind of just stealing and
calming stealing and calming the
thoughts and the mind till again so
there's
fewer emotions and fewer thoughts so
metaphorically fewer words on the page
and so it's just easier to see the page
um and you know
so those are four
i think four major uh ways of doing it
and then there's just the um
you know kind of like
direct pointing right now see it as the
only technique right and
that one
is always touted as the purest and the
quickest and all that but actually might
be philosophically pure or something
but
i don't know what the real numbers are
but i bet only one in a hundred thousand
people gets anywhere using that of
course the ones who do get there very
fast and that that's great so it's not
useless um and it is good for like doing
that
doing the trick where you can show a
naive subject off the street show them
their own
uh
awareness
in just a couple minutes right so it
does have that sort of glimpse
quality i could go on with a few more
but you get the idea there's different
routes in
some people dissolve
the mind
through just love right so some kind of
devotion or love and it kind of
dissolves the mind and then
um
if they can
just notice that behind the object of
devotion or within the object of
devotion
there's this field of awareness
right then that
that's another way
you know in my term all of those in the
in sort of the most in the broadest
sense are deconstructing
the self but
um when i when i came up with that title
for a blog ten years ago i was talking
about the elaborate vipassana style
deconstruction of the sensory streams
method but over time i've seen how
really all those methods
you could call
deconstructing the self
and if i was to be a little more
um inclusive i'd say deconstructing self
and world because it's also external
side and sound and stuff that needs to
be
seen as empty
very cool yeah so deconstructing self
and world
cool
and then
so you found that
um
because i i do feel like this is
probably the most
at least one of the most simple also is
just recognizing that the amount of
words that are showing up on the page
like as thoughts and sensations and
and
triggering your identity and your likes
and dislikes and all of that
um
that
quieting down the amount of words that
are appearing
um and becoming aware of like the
arising and passing of the words um
enables one to sort of
realize and then stabilize
um a lot more
quickly
yeah that does really help and yet for
some people
other ways work better and
also again remembering that
the words and
likes and dislikes and all that aren't
actually
in the way they just appear to be in the
way and so uh because they're on the
page too right so
in the long run we don't want to make it
somehow that those are the enemy or we
got to get rid of them
it's just a temporary
um
temporary
expedient way to see the page more
clearly but yeah it is of course very
helpful
cool yeah and then so that that really
resonates with um then
um so you would say like with uh stable
with realization and stabilization then
comes the the collapsing of the duality
and um sort of not for everybody but the
um sort of the bodhisattva essence ends
up sort of uh streaming through that
there's nothing better to do with my
time than at least try and serve those
that are seeking um to understand what
their nature is
yeah um
part of it is honestly that
um
there's a couple things one you know
it's not about me or my time
anymore because you don't even think
that way as much
that's still
thought and feeling and identity type
motivation right it's good motivation
but over time it doesn't quite come up
like that it's more like
uh it's gonna sound really grandiose and
cosmic but
i don't mean it that way but it tends to
sound that way um you know just sort of
like
uh the world itself is doing it
um
taking those bodies
by actions but if we're good at it in
terms of like personal thought and
feeling
um
you know the
the maybe one of the worst phases
of my own practice is the phase where i
decide i'm gonna be all compassionate
and um
and really help people and so on
um
because
i mean it's better than the opposite
it's better than not helping people for
sure i mean don't get me wrong it's
better than being a dick
um but
it's also filled with um
you know
in the background anyway there's a kind
of
condescension and arrogance and i'm i
you know i'm the one who is being the
bodhisattva that can be there a little
bit
uh if if identity isn't
fully dissolved if thoughts and feelings
if you're still coming from thoughts and
feelings
instead of
from like awareness itself um but i will
say
that even on that level
the motivation that
i find arising for myself and others
most commonly is just
um
it's just so hard to watch people be in
so much pain
when
you
know
that their
thoughts and feelings are the cause of
all that pain right
it's like oh man you're really suffering
and
if you just saw
so much of that suffering would be gone
and
you know
if you just saw this one thing
you know
uh but it turns out that
that motivation hey i'd love to show you
this thing
that comes up in teaching and that's
great
before the bodhisatt walking around on
the street
you know telling your friends like
your friend like just imagine your
friend comes to you and they're like
i have a terrible stomach ache
i might have to go to the hospital and
get my stomach pumped
and my partner is really um
needs my help moving right now and so
i'm really upset because my stomach is
sick and i need to help my partner like
that kind of thing
and even though like it might come up
like hey
uh i wish you could just see
awareness itself right now because you
see how empty all those thoughts and
feelings are
saying that is not
helpful i guarantee you they will hate
you
and so even though the urge is to just
be like i wish you could see
um
that gets translated into hey i'll you
know i'll take you to the hospital or
hey i'll help
your partner move or whatever you know
it's just translated into a different
kind of action except when we're
teaching and then that's people who are
coming to hear that thing directly i
have found if you you know if you try to
kind of put it on people like hey if you
only knew this one you know
and it it's it's horrible
and
it it's uh it's actually kind of awful
so yeah the bodhisattva thing that the
helping others starts to arise naturally
you just can't help it
but it takes
a little while
to um
get how to do it effectively i still
don't do it very effectively
yeah
but the mood is like you know if you
most people like let's say you um
you found a little kitten
and the kitten was
like dirty and scraped up and bleeding
and starving and
like there was patches on its skin
and it was
severely suffering let's see it's also
cold
and it's meowing at you
you know
mewing
begging for help
um
you know it's not like
it's not like this big vow
is required
anybody who's not a sociopath or
deeply allergic to cats or whatever
would um
help that little kitten they would
warm it up and clean up its wounds and
and clean up its fur and give it some
food and hug it
it's just in us
and and so that's it just starts to be
oh you're suffering how can i help oh
man how can i help it's just natural and
i the grandiosity of the vow i feel like
sometimes
really gets in the way
of this just basic kindness
that's there
so
if you were to sort of break down then
the
like
um the individual's room like we use
this analogy earlier the room
um or the yeah the page um
that
what like you would say that the most
common things that are appearing and
disappearing in the room um or on the
page um you would say that those are
related to the sense of self the sense
of world
um
the
um
and to sort of investigate
what the sense of self actually is to
investigate what the room without
appearances and disappearances actually
is or what the substrate
that
enables uh the objects or the thoughts
to appear and disappear
um
you you would say that that style of
inquiry uh into like the fundamental
substrate um is uh is one of the top
though ways
sure of course i mean that's that's
supported by
all the tradition it's supported by
practice
um
[Music]
you know do you need to
dissolve the substrate
and break into substrate consciousness
completely before you can notice your
own awareness
[ __ ] no
you know
i can take a person off the street and
show them at least regular awareness
right it's it's
and maybe if they're a little bit
talented even get
uh a little deeper than that and
you know people who have definitely not
dissolved the substrate consciousness in
some kind of deep cessation
um
can still experience awake awareness
it's hard you know but doing the passion
of style deconstruction absolutely can
experience
and can stabilize it and however it is
true that if you want to
um
deeply stabilize it in a in a profoundly
um
unshakeable way then
penetrating
uh deeply you know we're using all these
technical terms now you know into
substrate consciousness is probably the
best
but how you get there again if you've
already been noticing awake awareness
and that's already stabilizing and
you're good at the pashna it might not
be
just
old you know shamatha that gets you
there
so
um so yeah
lots of people you know
have you have you talked to henry
shukman right you know he's
he just got to substrate consciousness
sitting on the beach when he was 19. no
drugs
no meditation didn't give any
you know didn't give a rat's ass about
meditation
just sitting on the beach with
penetrates the substrate so it's not
necessarily the case that everyone must
do it in that way
you know
it's uh
there's lots of different
methods and also like i keep saying
that's sort of uh
the most efficacious
over time in terms of deep deep deep
deep deep stabilization but yeah
so and now if we were to
investigate into
um
how
or like what is mostly in the way
of
um the individual um
penetrating uh substrate consciousness
let's say or the individual recognizing
the room or the page or the ocean
those are different things but okay yeah
okay cool so you you take um like
substrate consciousness to be different
than uh room and page and ocean and then
why
well
um
what i'm saying is that as i just said
you can recognize awake awareness
without penetrating so
putting those things oh okay you mean
glimpsing is that right then yeah and
even stabilizing glimpses you know
so just you know putting those all
together as one formula
is a little
uh too much
okay okay so you would say that like
glimpsing and then
stabilizing and then substrate
consciousness sort of some sort of an
order like that that's not the normal
order but what i'm saying is that order
is possible yeah
and for a lot of people it's easier
because just sitting there bored out of
your mind trying to do shamatha
that's like monk stuff right that's
retreat stuff it takes a long long long
long time
whereas if you can be
pointed to awake awareness first and get
some glimpsing and maybe even through
vipassana and stuff some good
stabilization
then doing the shamatha will be
quite a bit easier because you've
already cut through so much of the
material
but you know what you're saying what
gets in the way
um everything gets in the way atlas
everything that's not just awareness is
something that people can get attached
to and get focused on and just think is
solid and real and and so it becomes
absorbing right
and um
uh and so
there's we have to start to be able to
notice our own
uh grabbing on
that moment when the mind grabs onto an
object
and then the tension of that grab so
you know like the vedna and the contact
in the vedanai and the
um
like
that whole move
if you can learn to recognize that that
that's generally applicable so then it
doesn't matter if it's
what's coming up
and um
the other thing is uh
that we can learn
[Music]
which is slightly different but really
related but slightly different we can
some people are just really good at
seeing or noticing realizing emptiness
in a general way
and so you start to be able to apply
that to more and more things
what usually gets hard
even if under really laboratory
conditions of stillness
instability
even if you're good there at
awake awareness nonduality real
stability
what gets hard is that then you go out
and
you know get in a fight with your
girlfriend and all of that's out the
window because the thoughts and feelings
are so
so good
it actually speaks so um beautifully to
the integration phase
um
because nobody gives a [ __ ] if you're uh
on a mountaintop um right we just we
just don't
but we do care if you can take what
you've
investigated in your deconstruction and
then apply it in mainstream reality
so then when you are with your family
with your friends um for you to be like
relaxed away from fixation and grasping
um people are gonna really turn and look
and be like how is that person so calm
how is that person so loving and so
compassionate and so that's like your
basic like mainstream sort of way of of
um
of of like phrasing it because it really
does boil down to like love and
compassion um relaxation non-fixation
non-grasping
um
and uh and yeah and i do i do really um
you said earlier um
that
um like if we were to call let's say um
um recognizing true nature as uh
substrate consciousness or or the one or
infinity or emptiness um
and then collapse the um the do
collapse the duality to recognize that
even the world is um the absolute or or
god or brahman or whatever um and the
individual loss and their ego and
separation is also still god and the
absolute brahman etc
um
that
um the main inhibitors um from the turn
inward let's say in deconstructing
yourself so like what like what is like
this is i think this is probably
what is most relatable i think for
people like looking back at my journey
and if i was to be able to share with
myself at a younger age like what would
be the main things um i would say that
the words that pop up on the page that
are associated with a sense of self
um
so it's sort of like identity and
separation so like the conditioning of
separation um being probably like the
biggest one and then um fix and then sit
when sensation so it's like not being um
aware and awake to sensation because
then when the sensation arises that it
creates a trigger cascade rather than
dissolving into emptiness before you
know you're fixating and grasping again
with your preferences
so
would you say that if you were to say
like two main things let's say that are
blocking um
the recognition of true nature would you
say it's identity and sensation or what
would you say or is there
um it's believing the dream
that's it that's what's blocking
you know um there's a reason they call
noticing
this
uh awakening they call it awakening
and that's a really really important
term remember
the buddha didn't call himself
enlightened
he called himself awake that's what the
word buddha means buddha means awake he
said i'm awake.
what is he awake to he's awake from
the dream of self and world
and
awake to the fact that this is all
occurring within and of
awake awareness right it's the awareness
itself is
what we're awake to
and so the biggest
blocker is just believing the dream
yeah and as
soon as you become lucid in the dream of
your life
that's awakeness right now you're in
awake awareness
and so
there's and it's you know of course this
is a kind of a metaphor but it's a
really really good metaphor
that feeling you have when
uh
just you know you're in a dream let's
say i had kind of an uncomfortable
emotionally not that fun
dream not really a nightmare but just
you know not such a great dream
and then you
become lucid in the dream and you
realize oh
oh that's just a dream
you know that's awakening
all the the the person you are in that
dream
the other people in that dream
at all the situation in that dream
it's not that it's not there
because you're having a whole experience
of it it would be ridiculous to say it's
not there but in another way
it's not there in the way you thought it
was it's really really different so to
me
that's the important point wake up to
the fact of the dream
that's awakening right and then
and so that's the biggest blocker is we
stay asleep
and so
another way to conceptualize how to kind
of lift ourselves out of this to wake
ourselves up
um you know i've given all these
different methods another way to talk
about it or to conceptualize it
is that we're raising our energy
you know
uh
like
literally the embodied part of this
raising the energy
um
to to like overclock
our sleepy brains a little bit so that
there's enough energy there to see to
wake up
instead of go back to sleep oh let's
watch let's watch another movie boo just
go back into a dream within a dream
within a dream and your brain
settles into kind of this
mushy soup
and so there's a there's a physical
way to go here where we
you know energize and uplift our energy
so that there's enough wakefulness
present to cut through right to wake up
to become lucid in the dream of life
what's
interesting there is like
having done a tremendous amount of
kundalini yoga in various traditions and
you know pranayamas and all that i
really like all that stuff that embodied
energetic awakening
what's funny is that can go horribly
erupt
because
um you are still
if you don't have any training
and you're still caught in
neurotic obsessions
like everything is still very reified
and solid and real seeming
instead of waking up from the dream all
that energy will just
get
co-opted by
your neuroses and you'll just get more
and more and more and more and more
manic and involved in the dream
and so it's really important when we do
the
um
physical energizing uplift
thing that we use that
wisely to cut through right and knowing
the difference between cutting through
and just getting more involved in the
dream cut through is the same thing as
waking up right we're waking up to the
dream yeah so to me that's the biggest
block is like
we're asleep
stop sleeping wake up
yeah there's lots of ways to stop
sleeping when yeah you know i feel like
your question in a way is saying which
part of the dream do people get caught
on the most
yeah yeah
yeah
which part of the dream do people get um
tied up in the most yeah yeah
and the answer is
people are different they get caught up
in different parts of the dream but
you're right it's usually
something about me
you know something about who i think i
am in that dream and what it means about
who i am and blah blah blah
yeah so yeah and not the and not the who
i am being the dreamer itself but the
who i am being the contracted identity
have a separate individual so
focusing on on the content
like what content's more powerful or
whatever
it's useful and it helps us to do
vipassana or more likely vapashna and so
on but
it's still pointing at the stuff
pointing at the content and instead
let's point at the wakefulness wake up
wake up from that content right now
nice
that's important
nice okay so
you're
when when you're when you're cutting
through um the clouds the thoughts the
words um sensations identities
um
you're recognizing awake awareness
you're recognizing the sun or the paper
or the ocean or the room and then you
stabilize in that and then you naturally
express yourself more and more in
service
to the rest of life awakening so in a
sense it's um i like how you prioritize
believing the dream as uh as the top
way that we get um
uh distracted uh fixated um
yeah that does resonate a lot so
believing the dream itself
uh is at the top and so to wake up from
the dream is to recognize yourself as
the very dreamer which is one infinite
formless intelligence
yeah although that's a whole bunch of
ideas on top of it it's and i would just
say yes wake up
wake up from that dream
and um and furthermore
um
you know yes there's the content and our
identity and stuff but if you really
want a lot of help
stabilizing uh
stabilizing your awake awareness
go do some therapy
you know do some some attachment work do
some internal family systems get
if there's a couple big
gnarly traumas going on or something
those are always going to stop that
stabilization
and so
you know uh people usually put the
sequence like
wake up and then
clean up and grow up and show up but the
cleaning up
helps the waking up and the waking up
helps the cleaning up and so
actually
doing good psychological work whether
that's
you know with a paid therapist in an
office or
whether it's with
informed peers who you know you're
working together with
sort of on the same level
that kind of
deep psychological work like ifs or emdr
or all that stuff really actually
deeply helps
the awakening process because it's
eliminating the unconscious blockages
yes
totally
and
another thing that comes up really often
is people start to wake up from the
dream
so they're doing the thing they're
starting they're getting it and then
they get scared
i see this literally every single day
not most days
every single day someone starts to
really wake up
and then they get scared
and why do they get scared
uh because they feel like they're gonna
be annihilated they feel like they're
gonna go away they feel like nothing's
gonna matter they feel like they'll be
you know a hole in the world or
something
and where does that fear come from it
comes from
believing your identity as the dream
character oh my god if i wake up from
the stream
the dream character will a
well not necessarily
um
you can be lucid in the dream the
character's still there it didn't go
away but
uh you you don't believe you're really
them anymore
but even if they did go away
the metaphor applies like
you'll be fine
and
actually better than fun
and what's so interesting is
uh for people who are having that fear
come up all you really need to do
is expose yourself
expose that dream to awakening
expose
your
you know neurotic
self of thought and feeling
a supposed self of thought and feeling
expose that to some
awake awareness
again and again and again and again and
again in hundreds and thousands of
glimpses eventually it realizes
no matter how many times we do that
even though i get scared no matter how
many times we do that i don't actually
die
nothing bad happens
um and so eventually the fear calms down
and you're fine but this is a real this
if you want to know a block that's a
genuine block people get scared
because they don't want to disappear
and it's just like saying i didn't want
to wake up from the dream
you're going to wake up
and you're going to be fine
now that nobody dies from awakening
i agree with you i agree with you a lot
it's actually happened to me several
times um in this last year is um sort of
going into
some sort of like uh
in a sense it was like a nervous system
shock and
um
like uh definitely a fear definitely a
scaredness definitely uh
um
like uh
sort of a seeing through the the
character and um and then
uh
and yeah you can sort of sense the
character not wanting to let go um and
then you realize that you know there's
only one of you and and um
and so there's no more duality between
the the character and the space that
enables the character um
and so then you
well at least i have been yeah just
associating myself more with what uh
powers uh the character empowers life
itself powers the universe um
rather than the
then the um individual um perspective um
and then
um
yeah it uh yeah there's there's a lot of
other things here i like how um i like
how you said um that the shadow or
unconscious
is something to investigate and in that
process you can sort of find things like
um your core lack beliefs of things like
wanting to be seen or feeling unworthy
or seeking validation and when you sort
of put the light of awareness on those
things you recognize
um you sort of liberate yourself from
those shadows and from those unconscious
which then um enables you to
you know be more free when a sensation
arises you can be more free rather than
get triggered into
seeking worthiness and validation from
people
um i've noticed that's been that's been
huge and then i also really like how
yeah and throughout all those glimpses
um there's never a time when um
the character just disappears the
character never disappears the character
is um the dream at the same time
and so
um i like how you say i wake up
i think that that's really good i think
that that's most direct most clear
i think it doesn't have many
uh i do feel like i'm slowly becoming
less and less conceptual
i'm becoming just more and more um
you know just finding the most optimal
ways to just point at this and it really
is true just those two words you know
wake up just wake up
um
and
and i think that that maybe makes people
go like what does that mean like waking
up wake up from what
um
and i i love that like i love that
yeah wake up from what that's a good
question
it's a good inquiry question to look
into you know
and how would you answer that to
somebody that asks you that
i'd say look
i don't answer that question because
it's an inquiry question i can't answer
your inquiry question all i can say is
yeah look at that right now
you know
look
in your own experience
what can you wake up from
you know right now
nice
yeah i like how you take their attention
to you know right now yeah right now
look at what you could wake up from
that's so nice
yeah um
uh
for many people you know they're just
too involved in this as a concept and
it's like just drop all that and look
right now
for other people
um
they're they're
just really caught up in emotions
a lot of folks emotions are so big and
so intense and so compelling
that um
whenever it's you know it starts to open
up
instead they go to the emotion and again
it's not that thoughts and emotions
aren't it but they're just if we get
involved with them
they start to uh take over right
uh um
and so
we wanna look i keep thinking about and
we wanna look right now i keep thinking
about the
famous zen story right of the first zen
patriarch so an indian guy
from a guy from north india goes to
china
and
is the founder of zen right or chan
chana
and um
he's there teaching his first students
to meditate
and one of his students comes to him and
is like
master uh
you know
my mind is so upset
can you help me i can't meditate because
my mind is just too upset can you help
me
and bodhidharma is who's this you know
the zen master the first zen master is
kind of
kind of hard ass
just a little bit of a hard ass and
he he tells the guy
he gives him an inquiry question
although he doesn't sound like one but
it is one it's like a call on right he
says um
okay i can help your mind
but first you have to bring it to me so
bring me your mind
and i will
fix it so that you can meditate
so that's a colon right how do i bring
him my mind where is my mind right
but he doesn't say any that he just says
bring me your mind and so the student
goes off and
it doesn't say whether it's a day later
or 10 years later but a student comes
back and says
master i'm sorry i can't find my mind
and bodhidharma
gives the big zen
slap in the face he says see i fixed it
um and that that's an example of
of like just look
you've got this big problem but look
what are we what are you trying to get
you're trying to get liberated from that
problem but
do you even know what it is go try to
find it
right
it's really fascinating like if we
there's no part of our experience
that doesn't lead back to
eventually lead back to awareness and
even awake awareness
there's no part you can look at your big
toe
long enough it will lead you back to
uh
your the ground of being your true being
or however we want to talk about it
um and so in that way reality is like
a knitted sweater
and you kind of just pull any
any piece of of the yarn and just start
pulling and pulling and pulling in the
whole thing will just unravel as long as
you
really look really look right now
you know
so
that's what i that's the longer answer
to what would i say if they ask me
um
what i mean by
uh
look at what you're trying to get
liberated from
yeah
i love i love that point too because it
uh it definitely accelerates
the process to see that
um
yeah bring bring me the mind or bring me
separation bring me the ego um show it
to me
um and i think that that's really um so
good so powerful
right
as an as a direct inquiry question
[Music]
it's usually phrased as
where is your mind
but in you know traditions like
mahamudra they go
really
overboard with it in the way i love so
like
um
what's the color of your mind what's the
shape of your mind is it round is it
square
you know where's your mind located
um what's the what's the sound the
texture of your mind they ask a bunch of
questions like that and if you're coming
from the intellect you just can't get
anywhere with it
yeah that's a ridiculous question and
and
it doesn't help at all but if you look
and you actually try to answer the
question like if i say atlas what's the
shape of your mind
and you look is it round is it a cube
is this
fear what is it and you look
for real without just thinking i already
know the answer
and you look
you can't
find a mind to give a shape right
and so they just go through a long
series of inquiry questions just about
that
it's very very helpful
the thing that we're
so concerned with all day
is our mind right like
how do i feel and by how do i feel we
mean
you know what are my thoughts and
feelings like that's our mind and the
cat the small m mind
and
it's not that hard to notice that you
can't even find the damn thing
you know
it's not located anywhere
do you also use the analogy of uh the
the space that enables the musical notes
i don't use that one but sounds like a
good metaphor to me or analogy to me
it makes sense i've just never said that
one
and then when you talk about the
so do you also create a
a differentiation in
self with the lower case s and the
capital s
you know that's like an invited thing to
do so i understand it i don't usually
talk that way because i'm mainly talking
to buddhists and they freak out if you
use the word so so um but i'm conversant
i can talk that way
you know
do you see another way to say this is do
you see capital s self and no self or
anata as the same
yes
yeah i do too
as long as you know well there's a lot
of there's a lot of i could put some
caveats in there but
yeah yeah
generally speaking for sure
cool
um
what would be your caveats there
well
simply did not go into each one of them
it depends on what you mean by each of
those terms but but yeah in kind of a
general way sure
cool
yeah whenever i think of
deconstructing yourself i think of uh
realization of no self which then is
realization of capital s self that's
sort of how i would say sure yep
you know these are there's lots of
language we can use to describe the same
thing for sure
cool
um yeah i've actually found that to be
um also helpful is to do things like
share that
perhaps
the argument of uh no self versus self
is actually pointing to um the same
thing
and um
and another good one is
um
perhaps um the duality of
of uh impermanence and permanence also
collapses as well where you start by
seeing the words that are all
impermanent and then you recognize the
permanent nature of
the paper and then you collapse that
duality as well so it plays into uh many
i would say like buddhist and uh hindu
ideologies that
um you can sort of begin collapsing or
another way to say it is you can begin
um
recognizing that the pointing is the
same using different words
yeah i mean i i think that um
uh awakening and liberation is a human
experience
any human anywhere
can have that experience
what they're going to call it
and how they're going to conceptualize
it and so on
is going to
depend on their culture and their
language and their belief systems and
all that
but
um i'm of the opinion that the
experience
is the same everywhere
yeah
yeah and then i would say there's also
different in a sense flavors of it also
so there's like different ways to like
liberate yourself from the as we've
talked about throughout the show there's
just different flavors of liberation of
realization stabilization um so
so that that plays into this whole thing
with the different um paths or the
different traditions or the different
ways to um become one with true nature
that type of thing but um definitely at
the end point is the top of the mountain
you could say
the end point is coming back down from
the mountain and realizing the
non-duality of enlightenment and
non-enlightenment
exactly yeah so once you once you
realize you realize the top is the
bottom yep
cool
yeah i feel i feel really good i feel uh
really complete do you uh do you feel
complete you feel good about the convo
oh sure absolutely it's a real pleasure
uh that you invite me to come on here
and i can
spout off and pretend i know it all
it's so nice
it is it's really nice especially i've
been uh i've been following your work
and i've also been um
becoming better friends with frank yang
who highly recommends you and you guys
have obviously become closer friends as
well and so um
we'll uh we i also talked to frank about
potentially us three getting on a show
together so maybe we do that in the next
couple of months so there's a lot of
different fun ways to play on this
that sounds great yes thanks for
inviting me on
so cool so awesome and then thanks
everyone for tuning in uh infinite love
for you thank you we would love for you
to check out the links in the bio below
to deconstructing yourself also to
michael's youtube channel you can check
that out as well um you can check out
all of his content on his website
go and support him if you find what he
shares to be really useful and uh and
enriching
and also like the video if it brought
you value um drop us a comment with your
thoughts on the video subscribe if you
haven't to the channel share the video
with other people that you feel like
this would uh help
and
that's all thanks everyone we love you
and uh we'll see you soon i'll uh i'll
go ahead and i'll
i'll uh i'll end the
i'll end the stream and we'll stay in
the studio for a minute okay michael
great